Well, our next talk is by Luke Herrington
on components as data, so a round of applause,
please.
[applause]
All right, let's get started.
Hey, everyone, my name is Luke Herrington,
I'm a senior JavaScript engineer at Four Kitchens,
we're a digital agency and we make big websites.
Actually my work on NBC.com and the apps that
inspired this talk, the API work.
And the talk is components as data.
Across-platform GraphQL powered component
API and if that's not a mouthful, we're going
to unpack it, don't worry.
I just threw a bunch of buzzwords in there
to get you all to come, all right?
So let's start with components.
Components are these things that show up in
our front ends and everyone across our industry
is using them to build UIs.
They're the fundamental building blocks of
a UI.
Doesn't matter what framework, what platform
you're building on, you're using components
to build it most likely.
So I think components win.
We found a really good abstraction for building
UI.
But what is a component?
So I like to define components this way.
This is kind of like pseudomath here.
A component is a function of rendering props
and state.
And those words might sound familiar to you
if you've built a React app.
Let's dig into those words a little bit more.
So props, I think of, as read-only external
data.
They're basically the parameters to your render
function.
State is going to be local data that changes
over time.
And your render is a declarative representation
of the UI based upon the current props and
state.
So let's start with just this simple example
of a component, and then we'll get on to the
API stuff.
So here we have a switch component.
A switch component has a label, it has some
state, whether or not it's on or off, and
it has some presentation to it.
You know, when it's on, it's green, when it's
off it's white.
So the thing about components is that they're
also composable, so we could take this switch
component, and we could add it to a row, for
example.
And say we take that row component, and we
add it to our settings screen and suddenly
we have basically a screen in our application.
So I love components.
As a '90s kid, who grew up building LEGOs,
I can't help but love them, they feel like
LEGOs, and they're genuinely fun to work with
and we see this happening in our industry,
it doesn't matter if you're building with
something like SWIFT UI, or React, ReactNative,
VUe, you're using this general abstraction
and I think it's because it's a good one.
So I'm going to stop gushing about components
now because this is an API talk and you're
thinking, OK, where do we get to this whole
GraphQL thing?
So, but I just love components so much so
I'm going to leave this slide up for a second.
No.
Let's move on.
So when you get into building an application,
there's these pieces to your app, to your
architecture, and I'm going to use this throughout
the talk to kind of describe this API approach.
So generally you're going to have some sort
of database or data store.
You're going to have business logic, which
describes the rules that your business wants
to accomplish and help the user.
You're going to have some data fetching with
some third-party or external APIs, and you're
going to be denormallizing your data from
your database with maybe some third party
or other API data.
And you're probably going solve some sort
of feature flags, A/B testing and then of
course you're going to have some sort of component
library.
And you're going to kind of stitch that all
together in a composable way into the pieces
and the pages or screens for your application.
So you can combine these things in countless
ways and it's basically our job to figure
out how do we, you know, how do we put these
together?
And as you're building these things, usually
there comes a point in the conversation where
you're architecting an application of OK,
are we going to, you know, take more of a
monolithic approach or are we going to decouple
and build an API?
So when you're decoupling, we've had these
kind of conversations before.
Who should use like a decoupled architecture?
What is decoupling?
Let's define the terms.
When should you do that in a project life
cycle?
Why?
Why is it a good idea?
Why is it a bad idea sometimes.
And how?
The how-to.
But one thing that we generally neglect and
I don't think it's on purpose but I think
it's assumed is where.
Where do we decouple our applications?
So in this talk, we're going to use our friend,
the decouple line, to kind of describe and
explore this question of where do you decouple
your application.
So as the decouple line moves around your
architecture, some really interesting features
of your API are exposed.
Some -- the format of your API is exposed
and the content of your API is different.
So let's start by describing a typical decoupled
architecture.
This is one that I think is basically assumed
in general when we build APIs for our apps.
And that is, that you basically decouple right
before business logic, but right after the
data store, and essentially you're building
an API that exposes the raw data of your data
store, your database.
And this API is going to have listing functionality,
it's going to have filtering functionality,
sorting, including, or joining of some sort.
It's pretty typical.
And a good example of this approach is the
JSON API spec, which is an API format specification.
In this format you're going to roughly map
CRUD operations to HTTP verbs and the queries
are going to look pretty atomic and low-level
and almost like a SQL query.
Where you're basically saying, give me the
authors and you better know there's an authors
table somewhere in your database.
And I want to get the posts for those authors
and there's probably a post, too, and you
can see what I mean by kind of it being pretty
closely mapping to your data model.
So I think this is what people usually mean
when they say that their API is RESTful, and
let's be real: No one really knows what that
means except for our fearless leader Roy Fielding.
But let's look back here.
This leaves, if you look kind of on the other
side of the decouple line, this leaves a lot
for API consumers to implement.
This leaves them with business logic.
Further API fetching and denormalization,
A/B testing, and the whole gamut.
So let's move this line over a bit to here.
So in this approach, you're exposing business
logic in your API, and this is a really common
approach for product companies.
You're still exposing the resources of your
data store, but you're also exposing operations
upon that date Y
This is -- it's more than just resources or
entities that you're exposing.
A great example of something like this is
Stripe's API.
Stripe is a payment as a service company and
they expose a really, really powerful API
for working with things like charges and customers
and subscriptions, right?
But you're not just simply going and getting
a subscriber and then deleting a subscriber.
Stripe also exposes parts of their business
logic in the API.
So you could dispute a charge.
What HTTP verb does that map to?
Not really any.
Any of these kind of APIs can get really powerful.
They're essentially exposing their business
logic to you and most of their customers are
going to be developers that need to -- need
someone else to deal with the hard bits of
payments, for example.
So this format, and the prior, get really
powerful when you introduce something like
HATEOAS, stands for hypermedia as the engine
of application state.
So a big mouthful there.
So let me give you an example of what HATEOAS
looks like in action and this is a very basic
example in my opinion.
I think pagination of resources in your API
is an example of HATEOAS.
So imagine that we have this listing API where
we're going to get a list of things, and below
our data, we're going to return this kind
of like metadata attribute in our response,
called links.
And the links are going to include these things
like self, next, previous, last, first.
So if these links exist, the UI can know that
there's more to see or that there's something
else before this page of the list.
So what they can do is wire up their UI, to
based upon the existence of one of these properties,
create a next button or a previous button,
and in that way the server is powering the
state.
We could do things like calculating the last
page, by dividing the total count of the number
of items in this list, by the page size.
If some links don't exist, then you simply
don't create the UI for that.
And the other really powerful thing about
HATEOAS in hypermedia is that you can swap
out the implementation without friends even
knowing.
So in this example I've switched to an offset-based
pager.
You can do the same for a cursor-based pager.
And because they are running a git request
for it, they know no different.
Super powerful.
Imagine doing that for your users, if you're
working on a SaaS and expose an API.
You're exposing all of these actions and operations
that they could basically generate and machine-read
and work with.
So there's kind of the explanation for this
architecture.
So let's move the line all the way over to
this other side.
And this one's a bit of a stretch, I'll admit
it.
It's not really an API anymore.
You're basically building a monolith where
you're sending HTML, CSS, JavaScript, down
the wire.
But it's a decision to make, nonetheless,
when you're choosing your application.
And I want to kind of address the element
in the room here, that the room monolith has
become this low-grade insult in our industry
and I think that's a shame.
I think it's a case of guilt by association.
There's folks in our industry that have been
in the industry for a long time and worked
on these large codebases or joined a team
as a new member and had this legacy quote-unquote
application that was really difficult to work
with and maybe it was poorly designed and
it also happened to be a monolith, because
that's how everything was built for a very
long time.
But just because the different pieces of the
application don't communicate over the network
doesn't mean that the app is poorly written.
In fact, I would argue the opposite.
You could take a poorly written monolith and
break it up into microservices, and now you
have two problems.
You have a poorly designed application that
communicates over the network and you have
CAP theorem to deal with now and concurrency
and consistency issues.
So don't go so hard on the monolith.
I think it's a pretty good pattern.
Monolith does not mean spaghetti code.
OK.
So let's move on to the next ...
this one's interesting.
What is an application that -- whose database
lives in the client?
Well, it's an offline-first application or
it's a local-first application.
And I'm really excited about this kind of
pattern right here, these days.
In a world where people and their data, their
private data, has become a product, this pattern,
I think, could be really helpful.
OK, I'll get off my soapbox.
There's some really interesting research happening
in distributed, local-first, offline-first
applications.
It's a hard problem, so you have an app that
has been offline for two weeks and connects
to the network and needs to sync with other
nodes in the network?
How do you solve that problem?
It's a hard problem to solve.
But it's a real problem.
If you have a customer who's going to be out
in the field for two weeks or in low-latency
and no internet connection, this might be
an API that you consider building, and it
kind of takes the form of syncing.
There's some really interesting research happening
in this spot with CRDTs, which stand for commutative
replicated data types.
Wherein you seepsly model the operations on
your data as commutative, so you can basically
not worry about the order in which operations
happen, when you reconnect to the network.
*
Really excited about this pattern and I think
more apps should be built with data privacy
in mind.
Data ownership.
OK.
So finally, let's move to components as data.
In components as data, the back end has essentially
absorbed a lot more work, but leaves something
for the frontends to do.
And at this point, the backend kind of becomes
a frontend in its own right so what this looks
like is an API that serves JSON, structured
in terms of a UI tree.
And if that sounds confusing, we're going
to unpack it and get some examples here.
So your components can be described as data.
Hence the name components as data.
So let's get to an example.
Here's the most basic example I could think
of.
A hero component.
So here we have a JSON blob with a field called
component.
That component field is going to map directly
to a component in your component library.
And then you have the data.
And the data is essentially going to represent
the props that are needed to render that component.
Any state that the component might have is
going to be locally handled.
So I wanted to address another thing.
When React was first released, there was this
big conversation that happened about separation
of concerns.
In the creators of React's mind, I think there
was this ability to question best practices
and I'm glad they did it.
But then also, with the introduction of hooks,
which is a way of abstracting logic out of
components, and suspense, which is going to
solve for data fetching and a couple other
problems, I think we've seen that the component
as an abstraction isn't necessarily the best
abstraction for expressing business logic,
or data fetching.
So I think that this pattern kind of works
with that a little bit.
So this is a scary part in the talk where
I need to load an iFrame.
Oh, my gosh!
It worked!
OK.
Whew!
So we used this pattern to build out NBC.com
and all of its apps, Android, iOS, Roku, and
the TV app Samsung video.
So we used this component data to basically
render the slideshow here, some shelves, with
your favorite shows, this is us, any it this
is Us fans out there?
OK.
How about Will and Grace?
It's the '90s, OK!
So we used this pattern at NBC.
We started out kind of around here with a
very data-centric metric API.
Including and joining kinds of logic.
This left a lot fort frontends to do and they
were all reimplementing basically the same
queries with basically the same business logic
and having to deal with all sorts of denormalization
on sides.
They were all doing similar AB tests, and
it didn't seem dry when ultimately we wanted
a consistent experience across platforms.
So we built this proxy of sorts where we're
including and denormallizing data from multiple
sources, multiple APIs and giving the clients
much more to work with and much less responsibility.
But then has we built this out, we found that
what the business wanted was a very powerful
suite of A/B testing and very quick process-platform
A/B testing and feature flagging and reimplementing
that across platforms was more work than it
needed to be.
So what we did was moved toward components
as data where we absorbed that work and we
absorbed the component library into the back
end.
So some basic components that live in the
NBC data model would be, you know, a slideshow
that contains slides.
A shelf that might contain a series tile,
or a video tile.
So those are what we're going to be working
with our examples here.
It's a very basic example.
So we chose GraphQL to implement this pattern,
and I think the reason we ultimately did it
was because of the types and the queries.
The coupling you of the queries and the types
in GraphQL is a perfect match, in my opinion.
The way that these types need to be shared,
especially in the component library as data,
it was just really powerful to be able to
describe those with GraphQL schema.
And we'll show some benefits of doing that.
So let's just do a quick overview of what
the GraphQL schema looks like for an application
like this, and this is again a simplified
example.
So we're going to have an interface called
component with a component field like we talked
about earlier, and a treatment field and this
treatment field was essentially our quasi--like
class name field, that works cross-platform,
so if we wanted a component to be, you know,
the primary or the featured type of component,
we didn't have to create a whole new component
for that.
We could just augment it with this treatment
field, like a class.
Then we have our video tile and the video
tile also has a component and treatment field
and it's going to have a data field like we
talked about, and that data field will contain
like an image, title, secondary title, and
percent viewed.
We decoupled the data from the component for
use if another data type might need video
data.
So then we have our shelf and a shelf is going
to contain tiles.
So we define a series tile in a similar manner
and we union the video and series tile together
into this tile union and the shelf data, the
data for the shelf is going to contain this
items field, which is basically a slot for
tiles to live.
It's kind of like children, but it's more
specifically kind of tied to like a slot of
components.
So we're going to introduce this new interface
called section, right?
And you'll see why in a bit, but this section
interface is going to kind of delineate a
shelf component from other types of components.
It's a component, but it's also a section.
Same goes for featured: Slideshow is a different
type of component.
It's like a featured component, right?
And these things might have different properties,
different analytics, information, and metadata
information, and so introducing a new interface
makes sense.
So a slideshow contains slides.
I think we get the picture there.
And then finally we're going to have our page
type.
The page type stitches this all together,
it takes a featured field, which is going
to be, you know, like that slideshow up on
the top at the home page, for example and
then the sections field which is essentially
going to represent all of the shelves in the
UI and the query will obviously take the name,
user ID for personalization, and a platform.
So that we can vary the same platform.
So let's give another example.
This is what it's going to look like in Apollo
Playground.
So here we have our home page.
We're using our page field.
We're querying the home page for user ID loop
on platform web and you can see here that
we're spreading our slideshow fragment into
featured, shelf into sections, and as we build
out more and more components that are of the
section's interface, we would add more like
a group or other types.
So here we have our fragments that are going
to look as you would expect.
And this is what it looks like to send back
a UI tree as JSON.
We have our page, with our featured section
and our sections array.
And we have our component, called slideshow
with items of slides.
And sections are going to contain our shelf
and in this case we have a top picks for you
shelf, personalized just for you.
Let's show another example: You don't have
to just build out pages this way.
There's nothing that is forcing you to build
out an entire page response.
You can build out certain features.
So when I talked about absorbing the business
logic, this is kind of what I meant.
One of the features of NBC.com or really any
media-streaming kind of platform is some kind
of continue watching feature where you can
pick up where you've left off the videos you've
been watching.
So here we've exposed a continue watching
field that just returns the continue watching
shelf, a bunch of video tiles with some percent
viewed, some images, and the UI is going to
map over this field and generically render
its contents.
So let's talk about this -- I think that what
we're describing here is some sort of design
schema, where your component libraries is
described in terms of GraphQL, in terms of
a schema.
And this is, I think, what we are trying to
accomplish often when we build a design system,
is we want rules, we want structure, and this
type system ensures that.
A great example of this is when you throw
in the schema and do an open source tool like
GraphQL Voyager, and you can see kind of this
component library described as a graph.
So let's look at page, which is going to contain
featured, and sections.
So go to sections, where there's a shelf,
data, there's our tile union, and then a tile
could be a video tile or a series tile.
With their respective data.
So what does it look like to actually implement
this on the front end?
We showed kind of the back-end implementation
and we're going to use React to implement
this.
So we'll start with our component library.
That's how most front-end projects begin and
we'll build out a slideshow.
A slideshow is going to have some state, as
to which slide it's currently on.
A slide number.
And it's going to receive props and remember
that the props here is the data that comes
from the API.
So it's going to include this items field.
So we could map over the items field, and
get slides.
And we're going to generically render the
children using this dictionary.
Passing the data through and the current state
of the slide member.
Here is a boring slide component.
These are just example snippets here.
So these dictionaries are where kind of the
magic happens here.
These dictionaries map to the interfaces ins
in our schema.
So you remember our features interface and
our sections interface, so we add the respective
components from the components library into
these dictionaries.
Then when we want to go render a component,
we use the respective dictionary, we grab
the component field, look up the component
in the dictionary, and generically render
it with its data.
Finally, here's an example of how we could
stitch together that full-page query that
I showed you, where we're using the featured
section with the featured dictionary.
Grabbing out the featured property, and then
rendering our sections array, and mapping
over the sections and rendering whatever component
we have.
So this is, I think, a pretty interesting
solution to a hard problem that NBC had.
And maybe you have it too.
Here are some of the hard parts: When business
logic gets fragmented and you're centralizing
the business logic, you have to deal with
it in a centralized way, and that it can mean
bloat.
And something you tried to dry out.
If you've ever tried to dry code with don't
repeat yourself and then it turned out that
oh, actually, I kind of wanted to repeat myself.
The same goes with variance across platforms.
If Android wants that slight tweak or another
platform wants another tweak.
So
we solved those by creating this abstraction
that we called the conditional resolver and
you saw maybe if you're here in the last talk
what a resolver looks like and a conditional
resolver allows you to essentially compose
an array of resolvers together with some basic
conditions that are going to be looking at
the args off your query, a the variables off
your query and the context, as well, and choosing
the time to run.
Another thing was pagination.
So we solved this by creating a lazy shelf
that tells the front end, hey, when you render
this thing, there's not very much to do, but
we were able to tell them, hey, implement
it like this, when you get a lazy shelf, use
this query that we're going to give you the
query name in the lazy shelf data and then
use these variables that we're passing to
you, and when you render, make this call and
when you get the callback and the response,
you'll get a component and you'll swap it
out.
So if you get a lazy shelf, you render it,
it fires off a request and returns a shelf
and then you just swap in the shelf.
There are some good parts, too.
This led to vastly simpler front ends.
it's a different problem set for them to solve.
It's not easy, don't get me wrong.
But it's simpler.
We're also able to centralize business logic
which has a lot of pros, lets fragmentation
and differences across platforms.
Also, centralizing A/B testing and feature
flagging has been a huge boon. same goes for
feature flagging and releases, we also get
this design consistency with a design schema.
The documentation for a component library
for a front end is described in schema, and
you can use all of these really interesting
GraphQL tools out there to document it and
finally on the server side we're able to do
some query optimization and caching that you
simply wouldn't have been able to do on the
front end.
So here's what I'll leave you with: I'm not
saying that everyone should use this pattern.
In fact, I would caution you against it if
you have a very transactional-heavy app or
if you have a UI that is very form-based,
or I think you get what I'm saying.
If you're serving content or media, and you
need to be very swift in *AB tests and you're
doing that across platforms, this might be
a good fit for you.
It's not for everyone, though.
And I guess what I'm leaving you with, if
you're going to design an API, think outside
the box.
You never know what you might come up with
and you can have some fun doing it, as well.
Thanks everyone for having me.
It's been an honor speaking here.
Thank you to the conference organizers and
come talk to me afterwards.
[applause]